madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal
le groupe axa revient sur sa décision
après le tollé provoqué par son
intention d'augmenter les contrats
d'assurance vie pour les parents
d'enfants handicapés une suspension pour
un an
les élections législatives en iran du
jamais vu plus de 75 % de participation
la gauche très formatrice pourrait dès
le premier tour marqué une solide avance
un véritable tournant sur les plages de
l'atlantique plus de 200 d'oufa retrouvé
mort il serait victime des chaluts
pélagiques une hypothèse récusée par les
pêcheurs et puis une famille d'accueil
jugées trop vieilles par la dass se voir
retirer la garde de deux enfants
aujourd'hui âgés de 5 et 7 ans un drame
déchirant ou non de la loi et de
l'intérêt de l'enfant sur les plages qui
s'étendent de la vendée à la côte basque
scènes désolantes images surréalistes de
ses dauphins blessé à mort venue
s'échouer sur le rivage mis en cause
certaines techniques de pêche utilisant
des filets tirés entre deux eaux
hypothèse récusé par ceux qui utilisent
des chalut pélagique explications eric
lemasson david basé
c'est bien connu le dauphin et l'homme
sont faits pour s'entendre sauf au mois
de février en aquitaine où chaque année
leurs cadavres se ramasse par centaines
après qu'il est eu la mauvaise idée de
croiser la route de la pêche
industrielle
depuis le début de la semaine 200
carcasses ont déjà été rejetés par la
mer entre la vendée et le pays basque et
scientifiques affirment n'avoir aucun
doute sur la cause du phénomène le filet
dit pélagiques utilisés par les pêcheurs
français notamment ceux du pays basque
et le principal ennemi du dauphin le
filet pélagiques est une menace
gigantesque traîné entre deux eaux sa
taille peut atteindre 400 mètres de
diamètre et 900 de profondeur a eu des
échos radars mais ne sait pas exactement
ce qui se trouve dans ses profondeurs là
il va récolter un peu tout ce qu'ils
trouvent c'est une pêche qui est très
peu sélective donc il aura des merlus
des anchois et puis éventuellement il
aura tous les groupes des dauphins qui
sont passés par là explicitement mis en
cause les pêcheurs aquitains se
défendent tout aussi explicitement il y
à des captures accidentelles
mais ça n'explique pas les 100 % des
échouages on va dire qu'il y en a 10 ou
15% qui sont dus à des captures
accidentelles
mais certains biologistes au lieu d'être
dans leurs placards ferait bien de nous
expliquer les 85% qui manquent
les biologistes en question sont
toutefois formelle my pélagiques des
pêcheurs basques ou filet plat de leur
concurrent de l'île d'yeu les blessures
sur les nageoires des dauphins ne laisse
planer aucun doute sur l'origine humaine
du carnage ses dauphins morts témoigne
d'une réalité dans son ami l'être humain
ne se préoccupent guère l'exploitation
industrielle massive du golfe de
gascogne dont les réserves en poissons
s'amenuisent dramatiquement le groupe
d'assurances axa fait marche arrière
devant l'immense émotion suscitée par sa
décision de doubler les cotisations
payées par les parents d'handicapés
claude bébéar suspend pour un an
cette hausse des tarifs des contrats
d'assurance vie aussitôt des réactions
de soulagement se sont multipliés une
victoire de la solidarité contre la
logique de la loi du marché jean bernard
chaix pour marie therese henry c'est
déjà un anglais n'y est pourtant au
début de la semaine c'était la
catastrophe
l'assureur axa a décidé de doubler du
jour au lendemain les primes de leur
contrat censé assurer les vieux jours de
leur enfant handicapé mental 7000
familles étaient concernés par cette
mesure
aujourd'hui devant le tollé général axa
a fini par renoncer tout du moins par
suspendre sa décision jusqu'à l'an
prochain mais les parents restent
sceptiques
il y aura de moins en moins d'adhérents
puisque c'est tollé il ne fera pas venir
des adhérents à la rente survie ça je
pense fermement et que quand ce sera le
moment à nos jeunes de toucher leur
rentre on ira ya plus rien mardi chez
axa on était plutôt faire la présente
nous ne pouvons pas continuer de cette
façon
pourtant aujourd'hui claude bébéar
président du directoire estime qu'il
faut désormais tout faire pour trouver
une solution avec toutes les parties
prenantes un bon signe pour
l'association des parents d'handicapés
c'est une relation partenariale qui a
rencontré des difficultés mais axa est
une api demeurent des partenaires vous
qu'ils construisent quelque chose de
positif
j'ai le sentiment que c'est aujourd'hui
la volonté d'axa mais c'est vrai aussi
la collectivité doit se préoccuper du
statut fiscal du statut social et la
collectivité c'est l'état pointé du
doigt un état sommé par certains parents
de faire plus un état qui ne peut
pourtant pas tout faire pour martine
aubry
vous savez bien que l'état ne pas
prendre en charge pour tous les risques
et tous les problèmes vous êtes invalide
après l'accident de voiture vous pouvez
plus travailler parce que vous avez une
maladie il y avait déjà des allocations
les allocation d'adulte handicapé qui
d'ailleurs se poursuivre dans l'avenir
encouragée par le gouvernement les
discussions se tiendront entre axa et
les parents d'handicapés lundi puis
mardi une concertation pour tenter de
concilier solidarité est logique de
rentabilité le groupe axa qui par
ailleurs a pris le parti de demander de
62% une assurance contre la perte
d'emploi un contrat qui selon le groupe
était en déficit
venons en maintenant à cette histoire
dans le tarn où une décision
administrative prise au nom de l'intérêt
de l'enfant va bouleverser déchirer une
famille entière parce que le couple qui
avait accueilli depuis plusieurs années
deux enfants aujourd'hui âgés de 5 et 7
ans parce que ce couple est considéré
comme trop âgées demain les petits
seront retirés de la seule famille
qu'ils connaissent pour être placé dans
un foyer qui correspond aux normes selon
la dass muriel la saga david bres
demain edouard n'attendra plus pierre et
mickaël à la sortie de l'école car
demain les deux frères ne vivront plus
dans la même famille d'accueil ainsi en
a décidé le led sociale à l'enfance qui
s'occupe du placement de ses gosses
délaissé de marguerite à 61 ans edouard
65 trop vieux aux yeux de
l'administration qui estime que pierre
et mickaël doivent plier bagage il y a
cinq ans au moment du placement des
enfants
là je n'avais jamais été évoqué et
pourquoi ils me laissaient les embases
moment là pourquoi ils changeraient pas
lui confie la fois qu ils ont fait une
faute mais cinq ans après sur un
décolleté qu'ils ont vu une faute à mon
avis on se rendait compte plutôt
beaucoup plus tôt par maintenant du côté
de l'administration
les explications sont bien maigres force
est de constater qu'il ya des situations
qui n'évolue pas aussi vite que ce qu'on
pourrait le penser
c'est ce qui fait passer dans ce cas là
tu as fait pour penser que ces grands
reste de flux moins longtemps
tout à fait c'est ce que j'en veux plus
selon l'équipe médico psycho social la
situation de la mère naturelle des
enfants auraient dû se rétablir plus
rapidement
cela n'a pas été le cas quand nous ne
s'affaisse savoir qui savait parler sans
fin j'avais des mal baisées mais l'a
laissée au moins 3,4 de plus au moins
que le plus petit et sachez qu'ils sont
bas il pourquoi ils sont bas face à la
machine administrative
cette famille se sent broyer depuis un
mois michael et pierre ne savent plus
trop ce qui se passe si ce n'est que
demain il ne partageront plus les câlins
avec manny depuis de nombreux mois on
s'interroge sur les risques éventuels
des cultures transgéniques en france le
gouvernement n'a autorisé que sur
certaines parcelles bien défini la
production de maïs à partir d'organismes
génétiquement modifiés
or voilà qu'aujourd'hui en alsace on a
pour la première fois détecté sur la
dernière récolte d'un groupe serré
et la présence la trace de gm une
pollution certes marginal mais qui pose
bien des questions louis carzou un silo
paralysée par un grain de sable
génétique pour la première fois en
france des traces d'organismes
génétiquement modifiés ont été dites et
que tu es beau milieu d'une récolte de
maïs pourtant réputé sans ogm colère
chez les écologistes qui voit dans cette
découverte la preuve qu'aucune barrière
légal ne peut prévenir les disperse au
naturel des maïs modifié
on pense que cette pollution peut venir
que des chants test et c'est chante est
normalement devrait être bien déclarer
en mairie bien il ya enregistré et il
devrait donc en fait c'est un accident
qui n'aurait pas dû se produire puisque
en alsace léon des articulteurs se sont
prononcé clairement contre les la
culture des ogm
les jantes est non déclaré des semences
modifiées vendu comme naturelle sans
oublier tout simplement des résidus dans
des camions ou des tuyaux d'acheminement
les occasions de mélange volontaire ou
non entre maïs classique et maïs
transgéniques ne manquent pas ce
problème de la dispersion cela fait dix
ans que les équipes du professeur pierre
henri gouyon l'étude y ait faute de
pouvoir garantir aujourd'hui une filière
0% gm ce spécialiste met en avant la
nécessité d'établir une norme acceptable
tous les distributeurs nous disent qu'à
l'heure actuelle ils pourront pas 40
hier des filières vraiment sans ogm et
où le seuil qui semble réalisable pour
les pour légumes pour les distributeurs
semblent être autour de 2% à l'heure
actuelle de fait ce soir c'est la
stupeur ce le céréalier car les dépenses
pour garantir le caractère sans ogm de
chaque récolte représente entre 300 et
500 mille francs et se révèle à la merci
d'un gran miles sur le front économique
tous les indicateurs sont au vert la
croissance est bien là et l'année qui
vient de s'écouler a permis une création
d'emplois record du jamais vu depuis dix
ans illustration dans ces secteurs
particulièrement performant comme le
tourisme ou l'informatique et milliers
d'enfants dans cette agence de voyages
sur cinq personnes trois ont été
recrutés l'an dernier sandrine par
exemple
j'ai été embauchée depuis à peu près
quatre mois c'est à dire fin octobre je
n'ai pas énormément chercher dirai pas
ce que serait que dans les motive tous
aimer est assez facile de trouver du
travail
le tourisme profite du retour à la
croissance et dans certaines entreprises
comme celle ci on embauche à tour de
bras sur l'année 99 finale 220 embauches
dont 129 cdi et pour l'année 2000 nous
avons des ouvertures d'agencés en
prévision avec une progression de
l'emploi de 3 7% 99
le secteur tertiaire remporte la palme
de la croissance notamment grâce à
l'essor des nouvelles technologies dans
cette entreprise internet on embauche
deux personnes par semaine depuis
septembre
nicolas fait partie de la dernière
fournée j'ai été embauché récemment il
ya dix minutes à peine dans le web
ça va très vite et ça va très vite et
tous les secteurs embauchent 350 mille
emplois créés l'an dernier + 80 mille
emplois jeunes en tout il s'agit de 430
nouveaux emplois depuis 89
on n'avait pas connu un tel niveau de
recrutement cela fait maintenant six ans
que le rythme des embauches ne faiblit
pas avec une accélération en 99
notamment chez les cadres 99 sera
probablement la meilleure année de la
décennie le marché de l'emploi des
cadres fortement augmenté au cours des
trois dernières années
juste deux chiffres en 96 nous avons
prêté 45 mille offres d'emploi 99 nous
devrions normalement voir un chiffre
supérieur à 90 milles mais si le secteur
tertiaire connaît une forte progression
d'autres restent en marge de la
croissance comme l'industrie ou les
recrutements n'ont progressé que de 0,4
pour cent l'an dernier
et puis d'autres bons résultats avec
l'excédent commercial de la france
approchant les 124 milliards de francs
99 un résultat en baisse par rapport à
l'année précédente mais qui reste
toutefois honorable compte tenu de la
crise asiatique et de la facture
pétrolière l'année à venir s'annonce au
mieux selon le secrétaire d'état au
commerce extérieur on l'a appris il ya
un instant les juge eva joly et laurence
vichnievsky en tord donné ce soir le
renvoi en correctionnelle de l'ancien
ministre des affaires étrangères roland
dumas
en marche de la faire f le président du
conseil constitutionnel en congé est
poursuivi pour complicité et recel
d'abus de biens sociaux
les réactions en politique se succèdent
ces derniers jours arnaud beauté une
mise en congé c'est par ces termes que
le 24 mars dernier
roland dumas fixer les modalités de son
retrait de la présidence du conseil
constitutionnel un retrait le temps des
procédures judiciaires
malgré de multiples pressions jamais
roland dumas n'a voulu démissionner
aujourd'hui son renvoi devant un
tribunal correctionnel relance la
polémique à gauche et à droite des voix
s'élèvent et réclame son départ
définitif
il devrait démissionner y compris parce
que dans le réquisitoire du procureur de
paris
on dit qu'il aurait entravé le cours de
la justice donc on ne peut pas même si
on veut se défendre et qu'on doit
pouvoir faire valoir ses arguments
on ne peut pas en même temps présidé le
conseil constitutionnel il doit
démissionner s'ils ne désigne sonne pas
puisque c'est une responsabilité qui lui
appartient je crois que les membres du
conseil conjoint elles ont leur mot à
dire
mais à propos de cette affaire les huit
sièges du conseil ne parle pas le
retrait de roland dumas a certes
modifiée équlibre droite gauche mais le
président par intérim yves guéna précise
que cela ne change rien au contraire le
conseil constitutionnel fonctionne
plutôt bien
vingt-cinq décision était prise depuis
le 24 mars
ce chiffre est supérieur à la moyenne a
nantes la mort suspecte le 8 février da
détenu placé au quartier disciplinaire
de la maison d'arrêt elle la famille ne
croit pas à la thèse du suicide avancée
par l'administration pénitentiaire et
demande une contre autopsie à nice garde
et rémy va saigner
zamani vernis aurais-tu 25 ans dans
trois jours il qu'on jette une peine de
deux mois à la maison d'arrêt de nantes
pour port d'armes prohibées
sa sortie était prévue le 6 mars il est
mort avant par pendaison
c'est en tout cas la conclusion de
l'autopsié pratiquée 48 heures après le
décès d'emblée la famille a rejeté la
thèse du suicide
ce sentiment s'est renforcée lorsque les
proches ont vu le corps à la morgue
j'ai pas découvert la tête de quelqu'un
d'un pendu j'ai découvert un corps plein
d'hématomes
depuis la plante des pieds jusqu'au
visage et là j'ai dit non non ça a
confirmé avoir de toutes façons avant de
voir mon frère j'avais des doutes mais
quand j'ai vu le corps de mon petit
frère
j'ai dit c'est pas vrai il ya eu quelque
chose quoi je sais pas j'accuse personne
mais je veux la vérité
je suis très embarrassé par le profil
psychologique hymne est décrit par la
famille qui n'a rien à voir avec celui
d'une personne qui a envie de se
suicider je suis assez gêné aussi par le
rapport d expertise médico légale qui
est tombé et qui à mon avis laisse des
zones d'ombré les jours de sa mort
zamani dernier se trouvait au quartier
disciplinaire
une punition après avoir menacé un
surveillant il est toujours possible
qu'il y ait non pas des coups mais des
des comment dirais-je il faut il faut le
il faut essayer de limiter de limiter
les coûts il faut aussi limiter la casse
quand il ya un an plus tôt en face de
soi c'est pas simple non plus mais des
coups il n'y a pas eu de coups de
données du mois pour volontairement une
information judiciaire a été ouverte
pour rechercher les causes de la mort
l'enquète est en cours
convaincue qu'on lui cacher quelque
chose la famille a demandé une contre
expertise
une demande acceptée ce soir par le
parquet de nantes
la grande-bretagne secoué par un immense
scandale de pédophilie à travers un
réseau qui ces vingt dernières années
auraient fait des centaines de jeunes
victimes déjà en début de semaine un
rapport officiel évoqué dans de nombreux
foyers sociaux les sévices sexuels subis
par quelques 650 enfants depuis l'
enquête a progressé s'étendant désormais
à tout le pays maryse burgot
l'homme qui vit ici est impliqué dans un
scandale sans précédent en grande
bretagne il fait partie de ces
travailleurs sociaux qui pendant vingt
ans ont été violents cruel envers des
enfants placés dans des foyers du pays
de galles une affaire de pédophilie
concernant 650 enfants est détaillé dans
ce rapport publié mardi dernier après la
diffusion toute cette semaine de
nombreux témoignages de victimes
devenues aujourd'hui adultes la grande
bretagne a pris conscience de l'ampleur
des crimes pédophiles
et depuis ce matin la police encourage
d'autres adultes a témoigné
éventuellement en appelant cette
association de lutte contre toute forme
de violence faite aux enfants car une
autre affaire mais cette fois dans des
foyers des environs de londres est en
cours d'investigation
le daily mail un tabloïd anglais prétend
aujourd'hui que ce réseau là est encore
pire que celui du pays de galles mais
selon la police et selon le responsable
de l'association nationale qui reçoit
les appels de victimes avancé le chiffre
de 11 mille enfants concernés est un peu
hâtif notre inquiétude c'est que hees
mille enfants ont séjourné dans ses
foyers concernés par la tête
il est clair que certains d'entre eux
ont été abusés sexuellement
mais ce n'est pas établie pour dans le
cadre de cette enquête sur
l'arrondissement de lambesc sud de
londres 40 suspects sont aujourd'hui
recherchés
les élections législatives en iran un
record de participation pour ce premier
tour jamais depuis la création de la
république islamique islamistes en 79
une telle mobilisation ne s'était
manifesté elle est à la hauteur de
l'enjeu
diminuer notablement le contrôle des
religieux sur l'état et la société
un tournant qui pourrait voir l'arrivée
de la gauche ce réformatrices proches du
président rate amis nos envoyés spéciaux
jean-marc il use jean françois renaud
l'électorat réformiste semblait avoir
largement mobilisés ce soir dans les
grandes villes pour des élections
législatives qui pour la première fois
depuis la révolution de 79
pourrait faire perdre la majorité au
parlement à la droite conservatrice et
religieuse qui depuis trois ans paralyse
les tentatives réformiste du président
rami c'est notre avenir qui est en jeu
et nous dit cet électeur je pense qu'il
est très important que chaque iranien
choisi lui même sa liberté autant que
faire se peut il fallait une bonne dose
de patience pour voter ce matin à
téhéran
chaque électeur devait dresser une liste
de 30 députés via moins connus en
général que les deux têtes de liste pour
défendre leurs sièges les conservateurs
religieux incapable d'inventer de
nouveaux slogans se réfugier derrière
l'ex président rafsandjani vieux routier
de la droite modérée
un homme puissant susceptibles de
prendre des voix aux réformistes mais
très impopulaire
pour répondre aux besoins de changement
des jeunes et des femmes majoritaires
dans le pays
les réformistes avait choisi un homme
nouveau un médecin de 40 ans reza
khatami le propre frère du président
cette semaine il avait fait un tabac
dans cette réunion électorale à téhéran
les réformistes espère triompher deux
mâts de l'obstruction systématique des
conservateurs au parlement
il rêve de remettre en cause vingt ans
de monopole religieux sur le pouvoir
politique économique et judiciaire en
iran sur le thème la démocratie est-elle
l'ennemi de l'islam
au contraire la futur allié d'un islam
moderne des élections importantes non
seulement pour un iran affamés de
liberté politique et d'investissement
d'étrangers mais également pour les du
milliard de musulmans de la planète et
l'avenir de leurs relations avec
l'occident
les premiers résultats de téhéran
baromètre politique de l'iran seront
connus dimanche soir ou lundi
moscow décide d'ouvrir une enquête
criminelle contre le président
tchétchène pour rébellion armée les
autorités russes depuis le début du
conflit en octobre dernier ne
reconnaissent plus la légitimité du chef
de l'état tchétchène désormais il
pourrait être inculpé est donc jugée
patrice ramdane sauf à pilonner des
ruines
on voit mal ce que les soldats russes
pourrait faire de plus pour tenir
grossemy et la confiance les habitent
à tel point que le ministre des
situations d'urgence s'autorise une
visite sur place promettent une
reconstruction est clair et sympathise
avec quelques civils au bonheur d'une
caméra complices sauf à être sourd
on ne peut ignorer la plainte de ceux
qui enterrent leurs proches quand les
russes sont entrés dans grosse ni 17
femmes ils ont ouvert toutes les caves
et massacrer ceux qui s'y cacher en fait
voulait seulement se protéger mes soeurs
elles ont été brûlées vives devant ma
mère sauf étranger lic
on peut imaginer qu'il n'y ait pas dans
cette prison des rebelles des
terroristes des combattants tchétchènes
chacun les normes comme il lui plaît
victime de sévices
tous les témoignages parlent de coups de
torture parfois de viol et voire
d'assassinât sauf a péché par naïveté on
se doute que si les russes ouvre ainsi
la ville aux caméras c'est l'essentiel
désormais se joue ailleurs au sud de la
tchétchénie où les rebelles se replient
et où moscou promet d'en finir avec
cette guerre qui a tué 1500 soldats
russes et 11000 rebelles sauf bien sûr à
remettre en cause les chiffres officiels
à vienne à la veille de la grande
manifestation anti haider plusieurs
milliers de lycéens ont défilé dans les
rues de la capitale les étés entre 4000
et vanier selon la police ou les
organisateurs à protester contre la
coalition au pouvoir en france deux mois
après le naufrage de l'erika jean claude
gayssot ministre des transports s'est
dit favorable à la solution du pompage
du fioul qui repose par 120 mètres de
fond une solution préférée à celle de
l'enfouissement sous le béton une
opération longue et coûteuse qui devrait
commencer au début du mois de mai en
poitou charentes la première vente aux
enchères organisée par l'office national
des forêts dans cette région après les
dégâts provoqués par la tempête
particulièrement violente dans ces
départements le cours du bois de haute
qualité ne s'est pas effondrée car
certains pouvait le supposer
en revanche la baisse est vertigineuse
pour le tout venant
christophe de balle embrasse alain
darrigrand donc je vous rappelle que
nous allons procéder par appel d'offres
c'est à dire pli cacheté soumission pli
cacheté enchères secrète la meilleure
offre l'emportent les sociétés
forestières achète les chablis de la
vienne ces arbres couchés par la tempête
dans les forêts du département donc
l'article 11 40
il s'agit de la forêt
maniable de moulière c'est évidemment
une coupe de produit accidentel
puisqu'il s'agit de produit accidentel
105 mètres cubes au total pour trente
mètres cubes de chaîne et 75 mètres
cubes de passing est importante cette
vente de chablis car c'est la première
dans la région poitou-charentes très
touché par la tempête et elle doit
préciser la tendance des prix cette
semaine ils vont guignard est allé
repérer les lots volume qualité avec en
tête déjà son idée sur le prix à payer
par rapport aux cours habituels vu la
quantité de bois qui a su le marché aux
comptes et 10 % en moins en moins et 10%
de plus de dambrun de frais dispos
tension parce que c'est beaucoup plus
difficile à exploiter que s'il était
debout entourant % moins que le cours
habituel
ou alors je pense que c'est raisonnable
donc une offre des établissements
provost une offre des établissements
dignard pour cet article 1200 222 1000
six enfants nos acceptez donc vont
accepter pour ce guignol mais ils vont
n'obtiendra finalement que la moitié des
lots qu'ils convoitaient les arbres de
qualité se vendent mieux que prévu non
ils font pas brader les décotes par
rapport à des arbres debout de qualité
équivalente
ce sont très très faible finalement la
tempête n'a pas fait diminuer et non
dans les bois par contre dans le
résineux c'est vraiment la cafal dans
l'airé dans les résines au sommet c'est
de au moins 50% quart de ces petits
résineux on ne sait que faire leurs
ventes ne paierait pas les frais d'une
exploitation laborieuses voire
dangereuse alors personne n'en veut pour
les propriétaires forestiers
ils feront l'objet de lourdes pertes les
résultats décevants de renault dont le
bénéfice net pour l'année 99 a chuté de
60% il ne s'agit en aucun cas d'une
baisse des ventes mais du coup des
préretraites et de son alliance avec le
japonais nissan
les explications de yann fronty des
noces réussi en mars dernier cette
poignée de main unis c'est le français
renault et japonais nissan renault
pouvait alors crié victoire
en s'implantant en asie un marché
prometteur mais cette victoire a un coût
elle se paye comptant en 1999
le constructeur français a enregistré
une baisse de 60% de son bénéfice net
un mauvais chiffres dus en partie à ce
nouveau partenariat
l'alliance avec le constructeur japonais
passent plus de 2 milliards dans les
comptes de renault mais elle est
importante pour l'avenir aujourd'hui
renault est un grand puisqu'il est le
quatrième il est juste avant volkswagen
juste après les deux géants américains
ford et general motors et le géant
japonais toyota
il est passé avec son acquisition de
nissan de d'un statut de proie un statut
de prédateur et on le voit aujourd'hui
il cherche de nouvelles alliances autre
opération qui grèvent les bénéfices le
plan de pré-retraites lancé par
l'entreprise un plan dont le financement
s'élève à 3 milliards 800 millions de
francs pour renault l'année dernière le
groupe a pourtant battu des records
son chiffre d'affaires a atteint 246
milliards de francs et près de 2
millions et demi de véhicules ont été
vendus
d'ailleurs la firme au losange se veut
rassurante pour les mois à venir
elle prévoit un résultat net en
progression pour l'année 2000 le message
devrait rassurer les actionnaires les
salariés et font grise mine
la direction a décidé de diviser par
deux leur intéressement aux résultats et
isola 2000 les surfeurs en herbe il
entre 5 et 14 ans et leur première
compétition cet après-midi concourait
pour la beauté du sport le plaisir de la
glisse olivier théron hervé pozzo
la valeur n'attend pas le nombre des
années et les microbes vont bientôt le
démontre ils ont qu'à peine cinq ans
mais ils sont déjà grands entraîné
sponsorisés et surtout motivés
bon c'est un jeu quand ils en paient et
quelques reprises des trucs comme ça tu
vas et tu veux ça leur permet un peu
amusé les parcours première course à 2 0
ça va bien chaud fort tu vas essayer de
faire quoi le chrono est prêt le casque
serré et comme les grands c'est parti
pour un boardercross un slalom avec des
virages relevés le snowboard a d'abord
séduit les adultes et les ados voici le
tour des enfants
les clubs sont obligés de s'ouvrir de
plus en plus surtout petit de d'envoyer
des gens en formation pour les encadrer
cas se sait pas quand même évident et
puis aussi une évolution du matériel
l'industrie a pris en compte la demande
des petits et à fabriquer de plus en
plus de petites planches parce qu'au
départ les petites et peut être
intéressé mais n'avait pas les produits
l'idée de la toute jeune fédération de
snowboard agréé par le ministère de la
jeunesse et sports depuis un mois c'est
d'arriver à ça chloé 13 ans et demi un
pur produit du club
quatrième aux championnats de france
elle veut allier performance et passion
quand je sors je prends du plaisir à
surfer donc bon bah voilà j'aime bien
faire des pipes des virages et puis
après en compétition contre des
confessions se retrouve entre amis on
est là on discute des résultats ont fait
des podiums ensemble les mini rider
microbes et autres on se refait aussi
pour gagner et là c'est déjà du
spectacle
rugby l'événement demain tant attendu le
match capital du quinze de france contre
l'angleterre les ennuis commencent
puisque alain penaud a été contraint
d'abandonner souffre d'une blessure à la
cuisse
les tricolores perdent ainsi leur demi
d'ouverture à quelques heures de cette
rencontre pour le tournoi des six
nations du côté des supporteurs anglais
l'heure est à l'optimisme ils espèrent
ils espèrent bien que leur équipe
profitera de ces déconvenues pour enfin
s'imposer sur la pelouse du stade de
france ambiance à chantier matériel de
rincquesen fred avec basket
regardez bien cette phase de jeu elle a
été tournée mercredi matin à chantilly
une demi-heure d'entraînement pour la
presse et le public
les anglais sont motivés et ont déjà
leur petite idée pour battre les
français
subitement ils ne veulent plus être
dérangé le huis clos est décrété allô
police tout le monde dehors
peut-être peur que l'on dévoile les
tactiques pour sa venue à l'horizon je
crois que c'est surtout ça difficile de
voler quelques images impossible
d'obtenir une interview cette semaine
pour rencontrer des rugbymen britannique
il fallait se rendre rue de berri dans
ce pub à quelques heures de france
angleterre
les membres du british rugby club de
paris se réunissent une dernière fois
pour parler du match
les pronostics vont bon train
apparemment détendu au moral en étant
tout à fait honnête la balance et en la
faveur de dvd français mais moi ça veut
dire les anglais de france ne sont pas
rassurés pourtant de l'autre côté de la
manche
la presse britannique a trouvé
aujourd'hui quelques bonnes raisons d'y
croire
il faudra trois français pour arrêter
lawrence dallaglio
selon les journaux le capitaine anglais
fait peur oubliée la coupe du monde
désastreuse
le quinze d'angleterre vient à paris
pour gagner pour les bookmakers
le match sera serré les deux équipes ont
exactement la même cote à 4 contre 5
ça ne vaut presque pas le coup de parier
pour le premier essai du match en
revanche emile ntamack est donné gagnant
à 10 contre 1 une chose est sûre le
joueur français fera tout pour que les
parieurs anglais
on est pour leur argent l'italie via
lors de la prada magna dans quelques
heures à peine dans la baie d'auckland
se déroulera la première régate de la
finale de la coupe de l'america chacun
retient son souffle
le bateau italien sera porté par
l'engouement de tout un pays
isabelle stress
tout est calme avant la tempête
a punta à la station balnéaire chic sur
la côte toscane
on s'apprête tranquillement à passer une
folle nuit
luna rossa c'est un bout de leur
histoire car c'est ici sur les chantiers
nautiques de punta à l'ats que le bateau
du défi prada vu le jour avant de
prendre le large
et voici qu'à l'autre bout du monde luna
rossa va défier les néo-zélandais
moi je fais de la voile depuis 20 ans et
l'italie en finale de la coupe de
l'america c'est un rêve sa feinte à
c'est une chose fantastique parce qu'ici
nous on a vécu avec ce bateau pendant
deux ans on l'a vu grandir
nous allons vaincre c'est sûr et c'est
toute l'italie qui se passionne pour la
voile on découvre lors de la coupe louis
vuitton qu'un modeste équipages italiens
pouvaient vaincre les géants américains
et les exclure ainsi de la coupe de
l'america une première depuis 1851
cette aventure c'est aussi celle de cet
homme
ici en rouge patrizio bertelli monsieur
prada cerveau financier du célèbre
groupe milanais de la mode
passionné de voile il a investi 350
millions de francs dans nous narre
hausse à lui comme tous les italiens
reviennent maintenant leur souffle pour
que le défi prada réalise l'exploit
la coupe de l'america et la compétition
internationale la plus importante en
voile alors ramenez éventuellement ce
trophée ici à punta là c'est une chose
merveilleuse mais la vidéo
tout est prêt pour la nuit à punta là et
ce sont 3 millions de téléspectateurs
italiens qui seront rivés à leur écran
avec le coup d'envoi dans quelques
heures de la première régate de la coupe
de l'america les italiens s'apprêtent à
passer de nouvelles nuits blanches avec
un rêve en tête que le célèbre trophée
détenu depuis un siècle et demi par les
anglo saxons arrive enfin
ici à punta à la les obsèques de roger
vadim cet après midi dans le petit
cimetière de saint tropez il cérémonie
dans l'intimité brigitte bardot qui fut
la première épouse du réel
l'acteur était présente ainsi que jane
fonda une fleur à la main
l'émotion et le recueillement autour de
la famille de roger vadim et de marie
christine barrault qui partageait sa vie
depuis plus de dix ans musique avec en
tournée européenne le groupe tower of
power qui continue d'enflammer les fans
du rythm and blues olivenza jean
françois meunier
avant chaque concert les damnés de la
funk un appel à dieu une filière avant
la débauche avant une orgie d'énergie et
de sang
les tower of power ont explosé à la fin
des années 60 ils ont enregistré ces
albums ont travaillé avec les plus
grands les rolling stones santana huey
lewis et ça ils en sont fiers
pour être faut être bâtis comme ça il
faut être musclé pour votre musique
évidemment après une traversée du désert
le big bang d'auckland refait surface au
début des années 90 et nous sommes un
groupe composé de personnalités c'est
notre pouvoir
chaque musicien est unique il offre ce
qu'il possède
on mélange le tout et on obtient notre
musique
à l'époque de l'hyper sophistication
l'état word power renoue avec les années
70 les années de la musique live
nous sommes les héritiers de la soul
music
notre musique est pleine d'émotion
d'énergie elle est très joyeuse ce n'est
pas quelque chose que nous essayons de
faire
en fait elle est en nous c'est notre
nature
mais cote le groupe de la côte ouest
américaine cultive depuis 30 ans son
sens du rythme
une chose dilami cuivre est plaqué or
c'est la fin de ce journal sans appel
les deux principaux titres le groupe axa
revient sur sa décision après le tollé
provoqué par son intention d'augmenter
les contrats d'assurance vie pour les
parents d'enfants handicapés une
suspension pour un an des élections
législatives en iran du jamais vu plus
de 75 % de participation la gauche
réformatrice forêt dès le premier tour
marqué une solide avance un véritable
tournant dans un instant la météo
isabelle martinez suivi du point route
valérie maurice de mein journée classée
noire sur les routes des alpes
20h50 nistor d'urnes à jour ma mini 5 le
dernier journal en compagnie de thierry
thuillier de manon thé ou café
catherine ceylac recevra pierre soulages
j'aurai le plaisir quand à moi de vous
retrouver devant dès 13h excellente fin
de soirée sur france 2